sun rises from glass curves so it's
gonna be more really hard to get like
what happens when you try to design
something
first your mind starts to expand
you expand your mind's Vision into a
whole lot of tangents that might not
really make a lot of sense in the
beginning
but then these are the ingredients that
you can use to focus and then narrow
down a direction and then you do this
over and over again you expand and you
narrow you expand and you narrow this
process is deeply human it's based on
our experiences our emotions or our
taste some might even say it's based on
our soul
a portion of this video is sponsored by
hostinger so how could AI possibly know
anything about this and is it possible
for us to use AI without losing our
human touch
you know being an architect I actually
thought coming up with the graphic
design idea for my brand was going to be
easy it's not the scope is definitely
smaller but it still follows the
non-linear process and in some ways I
feel like it's actually harder because
you don't really have any constraints
the constraints as you know set up the
guidelines for your project in
architecture even if your client gives
you complete Freedom you still have the
physical constraints of the site the Sun
the wind the topography and all of those
things help you shape the building these
limitations can give you Clues as to
what to focus on and what to highlight
and what to neglect and without these
limitations you can get really lost in
the process so aside from the general
graphic constraints I need to identify
some other parameters that's going to
help me guide the design
thank you
a brand is ideally something that's
unique something that stands out not
just a logo or a name but a recognizable
and a consistent identity that embodies
your values or your personality or your
reputation this was the majority of our
conversations at the beginning of 2023.
oh yeah this this edit looks really cool
but I think we need something a little
bit more like I think we need to animate
those people oh make them dance I think
used to make them dance sure no I mean
it's it's a great idea uh we're not
going to be able to publish for tomorrow
if you do that
well we can if you do an all-nighter
oh sure great idea let's let's do it
then yeah okay cool
travel South yeah we were constantly
frustrated we wanted to keep increasing
the quality of our videos but at the
same time we were bound to a one video a
week schedule we tried to hire more
people but training someone to think
like you that can actually take a lot of
time and a lot of resources that we
didn't really have that's when we had to
really put a stop to things and try to
evaluate what was our goal what were we
trying to do what was our vision so the
vision statement that we came up with is
to introduce architecture to a broader
audience and to inspire people to see
the world through A New Perspective and
these were some of the descriptive words
that we came up with to describe the
channel this actually gave us the
insights and the direction that we
needed to make some really drastic
changes to the channel to reduce the
number of videos but increase the
quality of everything we're putting out
so now that we have these descriptive
words we can use these as parameters to
create our design when you hear some of
these words words some images will come
to your mind depending on your
experience your taste or your intuition
like creative insightful energetic I
Think Bold bright colors or inspiring or
thought-provoking or Discovery I think
of a light coming through in a dark room
or a spotlight in a dark stage expert or
well researched it makes me think of
black and white line work or maybe
someone looking through a Looking Glass
on a t-shirt or merch I think simpler
the better so I want to keep the
drawings simple minimal 2D Line work
with flat colors so all of these images
make up a part of my design parameters
so typically I'll go to Pinterest or
Google and just start collecting a bunch
of images in a folder and this will
become a part of my ideation board but
now with AI you can do the exact same
process but you can generate a lot more
images a lot more specific images a lot
faster we used to subscribe to a stock
footage website Where We Gather stock
photos or videos but now we just search
for those images on mid-journey and we
can get specific images in hi-res and
very creative images a lot faster than
going through the archive but you still
have to do the work of actually
translating the words into images
because we did try putting these words
our descriptive words directly intimate
journey and this is what we got
[Music]
this branding process give me some time
to think about redesigning my own
website which I wasn't a huge fan of we
ended up using hostingers all in one
solution to migrate everything including
my online portfolio the resources and
the company website hostinger offers
everything from fast cloud-based
worldwide servers free email domain
management and WordPress optimization
they also have an AI powered website
builder which can help you write copy
create iterations of your logo and it
also has an AI heat map tool which can
help you optimize your website but if
you're missing that human touch they do
have a 24 7 customer service that's
always there for you they also have a
super competitive pricing plan that's
broken up into different tiers so that
it can meet any budget or traffic needs
if you're looking to build a brand or
online portfolio or you're looking for a
quick and easy way to migrate everything
from an existing platform like us you
can use the code damn Elite to get 10
off on all the plans
so over here we tried to do something
with RQ beans because that's the name of
my Discord community and you might be
asking why are key beans first we
thought it kind of sounds like our key
beings like
architecture beings and then you know
beans they're they sprout so they're
associated with growth
and we also thought you know arcu beans
it sounds really cute and simple and a
bean itself is visually very minimal
each Bean has its own characteristics so
we thought it would be cool if people
could associate themselves with the bean
like oh my God I'm totally a lima bean
no you're such a pinto bean
so this is where it gets really
interesting
first I asked chat gbt what are the
different types of beans and their
characteristics and then I asked what
style of architecture would you
associate with each type of aim and some
of the answers were really creative
garbanzo beans also known as chickpeas
are small and round and their beige
color could be associated with Islamic
or Moorish architecture which features
intricate geometric patterns and
decorative details and so I took some of
these ideas into my journey originally I
was thinking that the buildings could be
coming out of the bean like this
but actually I liked mitcherni's ideas
better that the bean forms an enclosure
and it becomes more like an Atrium space
but when we try putting on a t-shirt it
just didn't really look great it just
seems like it's something designed more
for a 3D object and we could definitely
print it in our 3D printer but we didn't
really want to go into that level of
production
oh
I'm really into this idea of a labyrinth
and a maze because for me they represent
a non-linear and sometimes painfully
long process a labyrinth is the longest
route to the center and during the
medieval times it was actually used for
meditative purposes because there's no
other possible routes that you can go
into even though the route is extremely
long and arduous you know that
eventually you're gonna get to the
center Amaze will lead you to zigzags
and dead ends but just like Labyrinth
eventually you will get to the end so
for me this is a representative of a
non-linear process like whether you're
learning something or whether you're
creating something you kind of just have
to have faith in the process because
eventually you'll get there so I tried a
bunch of different iterations of the
labyrinth but none of them really worked
for me they just look all too complex
and it just doesn't look good on a
t-shirt it kind of looks like a
microchip
looks really gamery which isn't really
what I'm going for but then again there
are people who
design can be really subjective
so let's take a hint from these guys and
maybe not go with such a literal route
yeah so
maybe instead of doing a literal
Labyrinth maybe we could do something
you know a little bit more figurative
on the front side we have a perfect axle
of a building
and then on the back side
you can have this kind of non-linear
process
[Music]
these ones I was playing around with
different geometric shapes and bold
colors and when I saw this image it
immediately made me think of like
pouring down a hole like the pantheon
[Music]
foreign
is one of the most recognizable
structures but what makes it so
incredibly magical it's not just a
structure itself but it's the light
it comes alive when the light enters the
building it's the intangible thing that
makes it special you need to really look
and you need to spend time there if you
really want to learn the essence of this
building but when you do it's magical
[Music]
this is definitely a line to my personal
design philosophy you know I really hate
things that are just so in your face and
I think it reflects the philosophy of
the channel as well I want to present
things in a way that when you really
spend time to understand something even
the things that seem extremely mundane
can be really interesting you know
inspiration is a big ethos of the
channel and I really like how when you
put a person here it looks like you know
a moment of inspiration or like a stroke
of Genius so maybe it has like a dark
background and a light foreground with
the person so I like this idea so I want
to do a series based on this theme
[Music]
anyways you can see how compared to a
traditional process you can generate a
lot more ideas and once you have that
you can very quickly go through a
process of elimination to see which one
works which one doesn't work or which
one you want to tweak to make it work
this is what I would call the narrowing
process you expand and then you narrow
so now that we have the idea we can move
into the design and the idea is a series
of buildings that come alive with
non-tangible elements like light or
water I did try asking chat gbt for some
suggestions but it gave me some really
generic answers and I actually have a
reason for this this is the Brion
Cemetery by Carlos garpa and these are
things that I noticed only because I
happen to be at this particular spot in
this building at a particular time of
the day if I went there on a cloudy day
I probably would have never ever seen
the slight effect and because chagibiti
doesn't have the personal experience of
going there for now it has a much harder
time giving answers like this
so anyways I've personally gone ahead
and selected a series of buildings that
I think have this mysterious quality
[Music]
okay so now we get into the expansion
process again we tried a bunch of
different iterations of the same design
so that we had a clear direction for the
rest of the images this one has a
photorealistic background with geometric
shapes and bright colors in the
foreground we generated this person with
mid-journey we found an image of the
style that we were looking for and we
remixed it with our own prompt to get
this geometric pixelation we tried a
bunch of different variations of the
same image to get exactly what we were
looking for
and then we brought it into illustrator
to tweak the colors we also tried an
option with line work as the background
which we catted up so that we could get
this perfect circle and then we played
around with doing a more messy scribble
look for the foreground and bold colors
we also tried to get this image through
mid-journey but couldn't quite get it to
what we were looking for so we ended up
hand sketching this when you're
designing with AI and you have a pretty
specific idea in mind you will pretty
quickly realize what's going to be
faster to keep generating prompts with
AI or to just make it yourself or if you
have an intern they can do it for you so
then we would compare these two we
didn't really like how this was creating
an arbitrary canvas on the T-shirt so we
decided to go with the line work option
and lower the opacity around the edges
so the whole t-shirt becomes the canvas
I think it's a lot simpler it's less ink
and it looks a little bit more elegant
but because we only had an image of the
top half of this person it didn't really
work with this option so we sketched out
a simple silhouette of a person we
iterated through a bunch of images to
get this Mosaic look and we used this to
fill in the silhouette
and we landed on this image then we use
this theme for all of our other images
[Music]
even when we were selecting the t-shirts
themselves we went through so many
options and so many iterations it had to
feel soft and durable and be a hundred
percent cotton if you want one for
yourself you can head over to the link
in the description for the next three
months you can get 20 off your purchase
if you use the code beads
whether you're designing with AI or
manually you don't really know what's
going to work until you try it
so it's best to try coming up with a
bunch of different options expand and
then you eliminate you narrow because
design is still an iterative and a
non-linear process AI allows you to
expand a lot farther than what you could
do on your own but the narrowing that's
still on you so it doesn't really matter
what tools you use as long as you have
these foundational skills so let me know
what you guys think about our designs
and our process and of course if you
like the designs feel free to check out
the merch down below thanks so much for
watching and we'll see you guys in the
next video
[Music]